once I caught up to the moment I had
left that ended all I've had to go on
since then are the plan and the vision
hey how's it going friends my name is
Pippa hey nice tie I should come to me
I'd seen that but I didn't know why
exactly or how it would end there is
you'll write my future aren't always
clear but they don't lie
speaking of lies Joyce's Singh is
discovered his brothers time machine
we've spent 17 years looking for it and
he finds it in less than a day those
sound unlucky
still we know it's out there somewhere
we don't know what his brother managed
to tell him if he really has located the
machine why would it come here until you
smart money says he's trying to play you
maybe but the machine is out there it's
in our interest to find out where what
the [ __ ] is going on I have to talk to
him do I get to play do I got to play
please please let me play I like to play
games
yes dr. Joyce could have provided the
answer to that question Williams
attitude and knowledge made him a
liability is that angry young man going
to court damn look at this flat yo don't
make this personal it's not but don't
forget why we're here tonight oh my god
what happened our people need
reassurance that we're in control
relax you're a date who could win the
mover yes okay little choice okay all
right so put on your speech I know
what's at stake here morning look at him
look at that [ __ ] idiot okay it's
weird how I get to play as a jack or
DePaul or whatever my name is uh
beautiful I want to live here I want
that wish this is my house [ __ ] peace
you get it fair to hit shut up we should
be set up by now
it's all on schedule you're
micromanaging again you're micromanaging
again don't even
which yeah don't even twitch buddy
you're gonna get it
tick oh can I can I get some of that we
are no he's I had to see the lifestyles
of the sick and trade herself close and
personal and it was such a nice
invitation you're rockin honey wanna
deal with this Paul kiss him kiss him
now
oh I get to choose Oh so I make the
decision to try to reach jack and make
him see reason or I could let hatch deal
with them so nothing would distract me
from leading monarch what all right
let's have a look let's have a look
let's have a look see what has passed
try to change things
uh-huh yes for me this question I once
trusted Jack more than anybody it was my
only chance to make him understand the
truth the [ __ ] do you mean nobody got a
look at the shooter without me there to
give the speech my Empire would start to
crumble like a house of cards okay that
doesn't sound very good for me business
comes miscalculation and as your dial 1
wins the doors for miscalculation also
come catastrophe and then
with you mr. Jones my old friend would
be a lost cause dead and buried along
with the rest of my past tonight is a
celebration a celebration face of
darkness tonight we celebrate because I
promise to you that we are prepared
monarch would grow stronger with my
presence the plan would go forward as
intended I guess I'll go with business
what are your breasts thing I'm not
entirely sure but I feel like business
make more sense Oh Oh God did I
seriously [ __ ] that up do you really
need a loading screen for that we've
been through this Xbox oh here we go
okay ah business we didn't come this far
to get derailed now you talk to him find
out what he knows
and I'm gonna fart in its face they're
all hard moneybags I know you want to
make this all about you and me jack but
that's far away in the past now and I
have a speech to prepare for okay so
what about this scene what is going on
here what happened
what did he see leads
I've been to the end of time and I've
escaped it all the way to 1999 when it
all started
I've tried to change things but by
tradition we made them happen in the
first place
oh we're stuck in the loop stuck in a
loop stuck in a loop stuck in a loop
stuck in a loop stuck in a loop Junction
2 business you choose 46%
all right well I I don't know I feel
like they were both pretty vague oh boy
it's another movie time this one isn't
as long monarch has been preparing for
it there's this thing it's called a
lifeboat protocol and it can save us at
least some of us
you've been the face of honor all these
years mark let's get clear on something
this is so my ship you're not being
Minnie burp when he said that sentence
this is so my ship oh yeah no no party I
think we're all together you want what
do you want anyone who might've broke it
Monica [ __ ] you wait wrong answer [ __ ]
funded step away right now
it was cool I they made the gameplay
match with their know with the movie
he's gone where's taxi guy on Liam Burke
he's armed and dangerous
then it became an action movie and a
nissan sponsored action movie I feel
like I should go buy a Nissen right now
Who am I kidding out I'll buy a Volvo I
was true Swedish man oh boy there is
another movie so it's like a TV show
slash video game slash should I just
should I just go like do you want to
watch it alone I don't that sounds weird
it's not a porno okay it's this kind of
strange alright this one isn't long as
the first one they weren't cool it just
caught me off guard like I was like what
the [ __ ] is going on what what
I don't like her haircut get a haircut
right look like my mom in the 90s get
out of here
that's what happens when you get
constipated really sucks the treatments
are losing their effectiveness fine no I
need to work on something oh she's the
doctor enjoy your so tonight I could
help us you work too much as it is I've
been running tests on the temporal
anomalies they're increasing in
frequency intuition they'll dissipate
I've told you that you need to consider
that maybe would you have seen this not
wrong
oh he's never wrong about it appear from
a speech I wonder if the movie changes
depending our decision as well you
shouldn't worry so much
I gotta say I'm more and more impressed
by this game I was a little skeptical
also because I heard about a lot of the
the critique of the game it seems like
people really want to rip this game
apart but I think it's only because it's
a really big title and people people
want to [ __ ] on it and probably console
war gets a little involved as well I
don't know I think it's uh it's it's
good you haven't touched your drink well
Sam does not have not really into
drinking a lot I guess
Oh rough day yeah this guy's my favorite
guy same hair we share their awkward
beard things happen in my day I knew we
had had to deal with some internal
affairs internal affairs
that oh you're just gonna leave me
hangin oh yeah it's internal oh she's
into him alright
I helped catch a train here today
traitor
she's the trailer yeah
who was it man hmm who wasn't she who is
it who was it yeah [ __ ]
they can't the she's gonna tell every
discuss we just brought it up like yeah
well I'm on our drama oh yeah I guess I
guess I'm just gonna have her leave you
hanging on that ah yeah sure she's
trying to play him I'm gonna use the
restroom you hang in here for huh okay
listen black lady mingle you're not that
hot for him all right
listen man you're a strong independent
man you don't need her all right
no you can trust her
what she doing she does she had the
power to look up what's gonna happen no
okay we just heard a fan
everyone constipated in this movie why
is the girl not there
do they not arrest the girl am i stupid
hey Betty hey you did oh yeah they
didn't I'm sorry I'm stupid I'm stupid I
I don't know what I was thinking I
remember they escaped thanks for the gun
yeah
dr. Ronald Martin I need your help
he listens to you Paul is that so I
think we're in trouble and he doesn't
see it he refuses to attend imagine
while I know you and I haven't always
seen eye-to-eye but I know you care
about monarch you care about what
happens and if we are reaching 0 States
something has to be done then what is it
we could do you know what we could do
I don't know what we're gonna do what
are you talking about up on top truth is
Sofia it's not really a matter of
whether or not Paul would listen to me
it's that I won't lessly oh I find your
approach to matters rather
counterproductive filling Paul's head
with your constant alarmism
distracting with penny doomsday
scenarios and if I'm being honest
I rule that they gave you a Markham of
function in this company Oh
unless you said I care about Monica yeah
what is it that you're so threatened by
Martin your face
No oh yeah you're threatened yeah that's
right I'm taller than you do I look
threatened - oh [ __ ]
Oh what's going on
we're just mingling slowly we will just
have a little chat even though that you
should prepare nicely I'll tell you
later
Julianne doctor
I was gonna say they move exactly the
same in the cutscenes even though they
look different they have the same
movement which is cool alright this is
that buckram Lisa give him a share
hey you're caca right Crocker nice name
hey Crocker its cracker get it right
Caulker really need to take a [ __ ] come
on
crock Crocker told you everyone is
constipated I called I [ __ ]
oh my god
what's our deal I don't like a where a
woman with the necklace my money is on
that uh-huh that's pretty good choice
yeah I'm gonna have to go with Ryan
Gosling down there talking with George
Clooney turn his nice cufflinks chatting
about stocks yeah Wow uh she's going for
it
BAM oh why am i around the upper ring
might okay now here's our rules the
rules are [ __ ] rough
you owe me another sword what a sword
what I actually hate olives man thanks
dear what's her deal I like don't get my
man drunk if you're not gonna punch come
on all right
ah thank you
just wish I wasn't losing so bad do you
wanna go for a walk
I love walks how did you know it's my
favorite thing in the whole world all
right what sword is she talking about
I'm taking mine too what ha ha firk
trying to do a crossword here by any her
if I have to come in there you're gonna
[ __ ] regret it listen this is just a
big Mis [ __ ] understanding I'm gonna
be out tomorrow Oh wouldn't good work
for you I will help you climb this
ladder all I'm asking is please let me
take a [ __ ] [ __ ] go to the back wall
thank you thank you so much um he fell
for the old lad you take a [ __ ] trick
back up slowly yeah yeah ok
really
that's all they took I'm gonna have to
remember that one if I ever go to jail
so you don't mind that we left you I
mean I wasn't really excited about going
in the first place
okay why'd you go I think had somebody
to us in my arm ah are we are we even
allowed to be out here yeah I'm sure
okay all right so what would you have
been doing tonight
he didn't go what if I hadn't gone to
the party with you yeah well I would
have cancelled all my other really
important plans yes well no I mean an
egg I doesn't feel like work yeah I like
being wired in yeah that you feel
connected you work all the time in fact
you're there most of the time I'm there
so don't work too much maybe I am that I
guess
oh [ __ ] hahahaha what's that mean that
regular laughs you turned on morrow boys
I supposed to do
don't make me look bad him for my girl
man I need to get in that lab to
something in there that I need the
lifeboat protocol you work with Beth
Wilder I've seen you before
you know her she's the reason I'm here
wait oh she played me damn it
I'm in him now don't look
no what god damn it come on man
that guns still necessary yeah
come on are you they're very kind person
thisis Christ
thanks for that thanks for that
subtitles it's right up here
we should refer to some tellers in case
you eat and you can't hear but everyone
hearing you can makes fun of you if you
have subtitles on you I got it guys I
got it I guess you guys can't do this
special talent I have
glad it's so celebrated you're welcome
is this it Hey
lifeboat protocol what is it is it
literally a lifeboat what is that an AI
what is that
all right this is where he did his
treatment
hey lady I don't like you all right what
the [ __ ] is that
I don't know all right why should crying
is it an AI was she crying
Kim Henry Kim hit the [ __ ] is there
the [ __ ] is it
Conine disrupted life-form extremely
hostile what does that mean
we'll never hurt them
like
a time disrupted life my doctor Kim got
stuck in time dr. Henry Kim hey looks
like before-and-after meth what happened
to your doctor can that's cool man
15 hours after fracturing time do you
know why Martin hatch holds up other
half what the hell's that supposed to
mean
I think the monarchs will be oftentimes
the Medes Paul may find them what
opportunity say yours assistant a little
more complex than that yeah it's a
little fancier title and then there's a
like now I consider your offer you my
condolences for your brother and well
you can tell me to [ __ ] off I can't tell
you Paul doesn't want you to suffer the
same fate and you could tell me to [ __ ]
off or I could point out that there's a
difference between Paul and myself
you see Paulie well he still has such
hope for the world whereas I lean
towards a more realistic approach
trouble is I believe that with hope
comes miscalculation and as you and I
one aware mr. George with miscalculation
can often come catastrophe
Paul's a very dangerous man practically
a zealot and things will only get worse
if he continues unchecked and that
leaves me with you mr. Joyce I'm very
confused by the story maybe you and I
can find some like who's good and who's
bad and I don't I don't get it
but I'm told at the end it's worth it
like it's a good good reveal so I'm
excited
well how about that is that a spray can
in a camera
who was he he was my mentor from college
and then here to monarch I was in a bad
place and he kind of turned me around
got it sort of I mean ghost files
bernetta mass deletion somebody was here
will get them thrown in field regulator
wait hold on wait oh [ __ ] this is dr.
Amaral's report what is it
the stutters they're they're increasing
in frequency
what's a stutter the more frequent the
stutters that the more indicative of a
fracture okay and what's a fracture of
time zero state it stops and it doesn't
start back up and the lipo protocol
could save us I have no idea but the
Cronin field regulator it is the core of
monarchs time tech everything is based
upon it and it has something to do with
the lifeboat
this way
wiki's wid them now
Oh Yoda why are you still caring the lab
is Sutter proof see your daughter where
are you going there :
honest up here we need them psych
finally
what are you gonna do man oh damn
nice ain't Brunt yeah one of those on
they have the time thing how could they
possibly win
thank you finally hahahaha yeah [ __ ]
let's go let's go let's go
okay that was the movie it's getting
interesting I'm really bad at watching
TV shows cuz I get so bored easily but
this one's pretty intense I gotta say
it's pretty weird this whole experience
I didn't expect any of this when I
started the game I had no idea I just
thought the game security was tight at
the monarch gala you took quite a risk
walking into the Lions Den if we were
gonna kidnap dr. a more all than when
you need to do it from the inside
Beth Wilder you were quick to trust her
yeah common interests is that all you
had mm-hmm so needed
thanks for showing up here I thought
this was gonna be a rescue yeah there's
a story here you know guy called hatch
Serene's right-hand man he was here he
gave me this big speech about how he
wants to take down Paul I hope you said
no I didn't trust him for a second
he of course always told me to wait for
an opening I just gave you one just
creepy
she freaked me out appreciate it close
your mouth girl you're not eating eating
yeah that's right
I got you like out there why did you
can't make yours didn't hear everyone's
concentrating on the party so far your
crazy plans working of course it is it's
my new doctor Emeril I don't have a fix
on her she's either at the party or at
her office at the R&D facility here on
the island I'll scout out the party it's
clear you're gonna sip champagne while I
break into a high-security installation
it's like you got this all figured out
I'll save you a cocktail weenie oh well
in that case my cover is I got to
survive the night Oh awkward girl so you
can't walk out the front door with me
this is the quickest way to the R&D
facility I disabled the security at the
back door but they'll be guards contact
me when you're clear where are we our
carriage I gave Jack yeah you know
what's at stake here okay this can't be
about revenge okay guys
I'm not here for Paul I'm here for four
and I swear I had the cocktail dad
thanks Beth oh he just screaming hey
Time Rush whole [ __ ] neo what's up
yeah that's what I'm talking about
that's it keep holding during timers
press B to perform a male eat a [ __ ] oh
[ __ ] [ __ ] yeah that's awesome let's do
that again when I actually do it that
will hurt in the morning that will hire
any morning and this will make you
regret your life troll the better sorry
that's all good that good all right
let's go if I could turn back time who
the hell designs these doors okay step
it up a bit I better better better
better better better better better bad
it's cool man the [ __ ] is this a
painting of a bet very sci-fi oh and a
very monarch
something tells me was it commissioned
by that now something tells me probably
the big Brechin hey Beth and I'm well
into this game at this point
oh I see
Jesus calm down tom calm down youre
shooting tree here what a tree ever do
it i better better better better better
better better better better better blah
blah blah blah blah blah we could've
warned me about that one Beth and you're
up bugger
how am I getting you that radar tower do
you guys like my cover I would crazy
frog thought it was pretty good
hate so pretty so cute I need to get
across somehow that did not was the
trick and I assume I got a hold down my
time thing as well got a backpack that I
thought bad I'd get it a dad good yeah
[ __ ]
oh hey guys thanks for inviting me to
the party
hi that was [ __ ] cool oh that's
something we can do here the whole rinin
felt unstuck in time okay
the whole can line of the old Cannon
felt loose I could shift it around nice
moved there but a smart post a mechanic
you guys get up come on that's how it
sucks
you'll be frozen yeah I know it's a risk
trying to think crash I'll keep an eye
out
see if I grab it for you I can just
shoot this I suppose orange go through
okay I want to do some more combat I'm
into it it's it's fun combat I got to
say just wish it was more of it and
there was a little harder yeah well it's
locked up tight now I hope they put two
in the back of his head
is it true he's got some kind
give it a bit bit better fit it surprise
[ __ ] oh my god you got [ __ ]
mate
alright sometime here shoot this [ __ ]
thing
oh god I got a shield what happened what
happened here we go here we go better
better better better better better
better better yeah dick shhh yes one guy
poor guy look you still lost he's like I
don't want to do this I don't even want
this job not [ __ ] worth what am I
even doing with my life where is she I
can't find him good night and just cuz
you're so stupid
I'm gonna shoot you in that all right
I'll be there in one second babe
don't even worry about it baby bet that
was easy
Beth I'm at the radar tower yeah we've
got a lab yeah where's the lab oh your
feet it's all top secret elevator inside
we'll take you down seriously what is
this a Bond villain lair you have no
idea just don't fall into the shark tank
do I look like a shark Beth I'm about to
take the elevator see Paul's still fond
of his own voice yeah he's talking about
a Survival Plan
crowd eating it up
evil corporations I am so pissed right
now so why would I hear again uh tacos
saving time something about you get made
um saving my brother up oh whoa this is
awesome
oh they're all dead come on open up
thank you come on
goodbye elevator is so cool hey hey whip
oh that was close
alright let's take him out
surprise [ __ ] I'll wait
ah come on let me have fine
oh no not the door my biggest enemy I
can [ __ ] tag bullet-like it's nothing
but the door no to get past okay there
we go
well that was easy hi guys now what the
hell is this whoa what the [ __ ] uh I
don't think I should touch that
being trained they're using it to stop
me and I like it
the device drain my powers we refer to
it as a Crone on damp of course you can
just call it time like you don't need
the [ __ ] fancy words light and [ __ ]
alright and up
alright what is this a crow none
penetrator that was some kind of
surveillance drone knowing the monarch
had eyes in the sky maybe a little
uneasy pom pom pom pom pom pom pom pom
pom pom pom pom pom pom pom pom pom pom
pom green order hatch to kill me because
you didn't want to push 100 scale of
that it's awkward I started to realize
miss Kunti whoa what the
maybe wonder the [ __ ] was that bozo oh
oh sorry about that makes gonna be fine
just slink through there it is
Oh Lee [ __ ] it's time for a bus stop
hole no it's andum well that's cool
yeah you
haha it's not the right sound effect man
cuz some of the dancers like [ __ ] it
let's just put a few oh my god guys
that's right sit the [ __ ] down mate
guy stuff what's going on wait I got
stuck ding what was we yeah oh whoa what
the [ __ ] alright let's do this properly
this time
god damn he just so much [ __ ] dammit
what doors okay this time what yes got
that [ __ ]
alright let's run around him that's not
running around mate there we go
how do I miss goddamn he's so annoying
I hate him okay here we go here's our
chance there it is yeah yeah but that
was hardcore
you're not even dead there you are
hahahaha
suck up my ass look at him go this is
the pose I want to die in giving birth
twizz office this way you might but [ __ ]
yeah all right what's next in this
platforming puzzle lair okay so I assume
we can jump between these huh and that's
what's done what's up everyone has to go
it tap a domani to you laddies
let's go across let's not fall down and
do all this [ __ ] again yes this is the
usual for year-round thanks I would I
would guess the same thing oh [ __ ] oh oh
oh oh my god that was so close [ __ ] yeah
hi guys really guys this is what you do
what are you doing stealing lunch what
an [ __ ] here we go
I knew the monarch had technology to let
their soldiers moving stutters but this
was bigger than that somehow time flowed
normally in that area suddenly monarchs
lack of concern about time stopping made
a hell of a lot more sense they will
create an area where time even though
time stops they can be alive that's the
lifeboat protocol
that's what moronic does mornig knows
that they can't they can't fix it oh hey
how you doing there no I just got some
boxes I don't really do anything I just
pretend to work
yeah me too let's just keep talking [ __ ]
doors in this game in all right where
the [ __ ] is this admah armor all no
alarms oh [ __ ] I dropped my pieces this
job when I can't my staff sit as animals
office I began that there looks like
what Beth Lloyd refining she wanted a
fanny pack
the party sir must never find way out
here gates the party yeah let's get to
the party hi he's waving
that's so cute I wish we could give them
all back to him that'd be funny haha
just to put him all in his hand or on
top of his head or some [ __ ] quite
explain oh no fun allowed still bill me
I knew best cover wouldn't last long I
had to get it to her at the party please
talk to her anyway
this is it this is the party good party
guys Brenner's mug yeah no that's
interesting what do these guys get their
money from guns me to operate in stutter
Paul had clear priorities time ends guns
don't
that was poetic and deep that's why I
love you that's why I have such a crush
on you man
here we go act 3 part 2 all right
part 2 well I think that's a good time
to end this episode if you enjoyed leave
a like I hope you bros enjoyed watching
I really appreciate their yeah you you
you do and it's a lot of fun for me to
play and I'll see you breast in the next
one is always stay awesome breasts oh my
god that's awesome can we kill someone
with it
hey deadly robot excuse me [ __ ]
yeah